all right so uh
and he's pushed he's pushing at me
my ego tried park type makes me push at
him makes me relax
i'm sorry it makes me tense well what i
want to do is
not add that tension i don't want to add
that closed
body body stays open okay
so what i'm going to do is create two
events where i'm
tempted or triggered to close so
right here you're going to feel oh it's
like if i don't
reach out he's going to knock me down
okay so
he's got pressure so all releasing you
that's he's pushing on me you see okay
it's
it's just as he's here his energy is
going past me to the ground so it looks
like he's not pushing but if i
if i release this thing he's pushing
through okay
all right so now i'm gonna do it this
releasing this openness
i'm gonna do it in an active way okay
so i'm gonna create a trigger here
one and then i'm gonna increase the
triggering by pushing
him and not resorting to this closeness
okay so i keep my joints open i don't
let him compact
and i don't compact him by pushing into
him i keep the joints open
keep my mind open again he's pushing to
trigger me
but it doesn't do it i just keep the
joints
don't try to do any kind of uh arm
manipulation you do you want all his
weight if i want
i want his weight oh i want his weight
and then i want his weight
and i release and keep the joints open
[Music]
and i start opening more parts of my box
everything gets open
i'm starting to get uh watch watch the
beginning you see it's all stiff
you see and then it kind of as i start
to understand
that i can maintain the openness
openness of my joints
and i'm going to take away all of that
everything is very fluid
[Music]
he
there's a lot of pushing there's a lot
of pressure there okay
it doesn't look like it because it's
going through me okay
and i'm not pushing on it all right okay
let's try to
start loosening everything okay
and see if you don't start compacting
your joints now
okay so when we think in terms of the
ego tripartite being
closed having constricted joints closed
joints compressed joints it's
dichotomous
that's that's it's a dichotomous mind
okay so you have to watch that
in the desire to push him you have the
dichotomous mind
and the joints will close okay so you
have to not only
release your body from the tension you
have to release your
mind from the desire to do something to
him
okay so that's what's happening here the
desire
to not get knocked over by him the
desire to push him over all that has to
all that has to be released
[Music]
and this is why you can do it with two
people so one wants to be on the outside
of each other
okay so right now your your ego trap
heartbreak goes oh
not two of you but it's not there's not
two there's just there's just the same
feeling
i work the same feeling this is the same
feeling okay
it's when when i push into this thing
that's when i feel two people
but when i just feel the drill it
doesn't matter
so i feel them and i just released
they're tempting me they're triggering
the f out of me you see
oh don't get triggered
just release the dice
again you can see holy cow holy cow
okay well it doesn't matter
don't have a desire to throw
don't have a desire there's two against
one just work your drill
release the tension everywhere
okay and i want you to feel it
because they're going to trigger you and
i want you to go oh yeah that's what's
happening to me okay go so that's
that's a progression drill so i there is
a kind of openness
meditation that you have to do at the
mind body level okay
um but that part of that openness is
really just about dropping the dichotomy
so the same thing like doing something
to him is
dichotomous um
so maybe you'll go like here and now
you're like
i want to throw him and now you're
pushing you see um and then this drill
you won't be able to progress by so you
can do a lot
you can do a lot of your ikea with this
drill
a lot of people that are good they can
do that skill okay
but why is that skill actually working
is because i don't contest him
internally
and his energy is going through me okay
i'm just doing it i'm i am continually
letting his energy go through me as i go
forward okay so if he has two hands i'm
not
contesting here he's he's pushing i'm
just letting it go through
okay and the reason why i wanted to go
through me is i don't want to be
dependent upon this external
displacement
okay so you have to drop the last little
bit of desire
gosh you're going to drop you got to
release that
because what i want is i want to get him
to give me a lot
a lot of energy and that energy goes
through
can you see and now now i'm doing the
same exact releasing skill
keeping my joints open i'm just letting
his energy go
boom and back out so gives a lot of
energy
and you will never get that skill if you
were doing
that okay 32 hands
this is going to require a quicker
releasing you see
so he's going to you're going to feel
that you're going to go
and then it's not going to go through
you so it has to be quick
okay try it at that level